actually you know you have to do it with
Arianna but you've known her since she
was little right since she was 7 years
old Arianna Grande she came there we are
we did hairspray Live Together I love
that child as she came back to see
Wicked her grandma brought her and she
said my my granddaughter wants a saying
I said oh well that's sweet you know
good luck superstar okay we'll see and
then she kind of thinks that thing and I
was like oh I checked myself because it
was really good and I said here's a
little wand because I created the role
of Glinda and I said keep that with you
and and have that with you and she kept
it all these years we've stayed close
and I I wanted to bring I wanted to
bring her in the record and we did you
don't own me Lesley Gore's tune and it's
I'm so proud of her yeah I love my god
that's so cool I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this